okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about wolf language
design this is part of our language
completeness and consistency
series our first topic is
a an option for delete object
and i guess this has come up because we
had a
an unfortunate situation with somebody
who deleted their home directory in the
cloud
and uh it's kind of like typing rm-r
star in unix
and everything went away and that's
super traumatic
so what we do with delete directory
is we have a a delete contents
with contents is right which is just
like the f the the rm f or something
while it's the uh it's the rf of uh rm
right it goes recursively in and deletes
everything inside of it
um
yes but delete
with contents or delete contents no it's
oh it is it is the least font yeah it's
delete contents yeah all right why is it
the case that when i am in here
and i hit return at that stage that it
gets confused
because
it accept it
thinks you're asking for a search you
need to press down arrow once to accept
that suggestion and then it will
which if there are multiple things still
there is obviously the correct behavior
it's a bit more debatable whether when
there's only one thing if it should
still behave that way
yeah i think that's a user assistance
topic if somebody can put it in that
meeting that would be good
i've got a note
um
it occurs to me we should be live
streaming the user assistance stuff
for people who are interested
um okay
okay so delete object
when applied to a cloud object that is a
directory
if the default setting for delete
contents is false
then it will refuse to delete it
and that would have solved the problem
that happened right now is that correct
yep
right on the other hand changing the
default would break a great deal of
non-experimental code so
right so so i i think i think there are
there
you know i've listed a a few different
issues right so so
one thing is right you can use delete
file and delete directory on cloud
objects so if you want something that
behaves like delete file or delete
directory you can just use those
um
and delete content is a little bit weird
for
you know then there's a naming thing
yeah i agree it's it's a little weird i
mean it makes sense when it's delete
directory but when it's delete object
which can be any sort of
so if i say delete file on a cloud
object that is a file it will just do
the do the right thing it will delete
the cloud object yep correct
okay so
in the case that happened here
the user should have used delete file is
that correct
i think so
and then delete file would have said
that this is in the file uh
can't do that
right and if they'd said delete
directory
it would have said this thing is not
empty
correct
i think the documentation promotes
delete object because then you don't
have to worry about doing a bunch of
checks on what the actual
object is so the documentation should
change yeah
but that's the that's why it's i think
we
again i'm not sure but i think that's
what bob had talked about before but we
sort of promote delete object more
for cloud
for cloud stuff
we shouldn't i mean this is the argument
for not doing that
i think we should talk about all of them
yeah
well i think we should like i mean
delete object i think
yeah i think that yeah the documentation
page on cloud objects should have
an example of delete file delete
directory and delete object right boom
boom
right and compare that let's say what
the difference is yeah
yeah
i'd say delete object will work with no
questions asked on anything right
on odu do you think that's a
satisfactory solution
there's especially cases where like you
know it's you have an index.html and you
don't even realize that the cloud object
is a directory
and you just want to use delete object
right
uh
definitely they're definitely good use
cases for delete object on cloud object
i know do you have any further comments
on this
i mean there's two options either you
know delete object takes an option like
we just went through this we just went
through this we don't think that's a
good idea because we can't change the
default
right we can't change the default so
taking an option isn't really going to
help anybody they're still going to get
they're still going to blow themselves
up
unless they read the documentation
carefully enough to know by the time
they're reading the documentation that
carefully they're probably not typing rm
our star
you know on on the top level directory
so then what are you suggesting delete
what what what we just said that we
promote delete file and delete directory
to be the things you use to delete files
and directories in the cloud cloud and
delete object is a lower level operation
that you use sparingly just like you use
rm
dash r
f star sparingly in unix
but it would still delete directories if
you use delete object yes it would
yes it would okay then i disagree with
that okay but you're wrong because we
can't change it for the reasons that
were just said we can put another option
in and nobody will ever see it and we'll
have the exact same problem sorry i'm
just advocating you know what i think
what are you advocating you're
advocating that we break tons of code
that says delete object because one user
typed the wrong thing no we're not going
to do that
end of story
i mean this was a pure user error
correct there was no there no system
error this was a pure user error they
typed delete object on their home
directory is that correct that's correct
and there are uh some safeguards on the
cloud side so you can't actually delete
your root directory but you can still
delete anything underneath it
so that's what happened
right i mean it's very unfortunate and i
feel for that that that that person you
know i've made mistakes like that myself
not for a long time i have to say
touchwood um but
you know
i did it i did it just last month and
that that's why that's why i have
nightly backups
yeah
well
i mean and hopefully we have appropriate
backups and so on that's a different
issue yep right better safeguards for
the right
what's that directory
are there safeguards for the root
directory
specifically so uh
just on just our on our end in case
there was uh
bad code on our end or other stuff like
that i i don't i don't know the specific
reasoning i just know it's there
i know that joel and and the cloud
object team had it there
we removed that we need our own dog
sorry i say it again why don't we remove
that and eat our own dog food
well
and you certainly don't want somebody to
put a file at their home directory yeah
there's a directory yeah
and
that's more a feature on cloud that's
not really
you know the fact that it's there isn't
really
super relevant to delete object it just
i don't think that's a bad safeguard i
think that's something that's a little
thing to do given that we have you know
user
some anchoring of users
i it makes sense to me
i think we're done with this particular
thing but we need to make sure that we
do a good job
of you know changing the way the
documentation encourages people to use
delete file and delete directory right
and and certainly if tech support you
know peter if if you have opinions that
you want to share on how to write it or
and or you want help creating specific
tech support notes you know i'm i'm
certainly available i don't want to be
volunteer john but i'm i'm reasonably
confident that john would also be
available
right
i think that's participated
okay let's go on to the next topic if we
can and the people who are here for
delete object can can drop if they wish
okay date string format
right so this is uh something that uh
was brought to me that apparently if
you're
using a desk topple from language then
there's a universal default of
you know right which i think is the us
you know short version if i recall
correctly and on the can i report this
or is it something somebody else um no
this this came up from cloud it caused
caused some issues and various cloud uh
handling to where if you're in a
uh depending on your time zone you got
you got a different date string format
and then
certain code thoughts you were in the
future and didn't handle that well and
other things like that so it was sort of
an unexpected result from
uh how this was there or or people who
do who try to you know rely on data yeah
right people who try to parse state
strings themselves and and don't take
into account dollar date stream format
and then they would get errors
because you know it was a date stream
format ended up being ambiguous or wrong
from what they were or you know
different from what they were expecting
i'm sorry i was not paying enough
attention here could you could you try
again please
what is the proposal so i the proposal
is to make cloud make
you know chain make cloud
match desktop or dollar date string
format always has there's a little proto
say yes there's a little prototype
example in the next uh section
right date time short
right
so and desktop you know any copy of
mathematica you know if if you're in
greece if you
if you have a desktop in greece or if
you take your laptop to china right you
always get that whereas
in the cloud it sort of depends on your
geo location
um
oh wow why is that
so different is that
it's always like that in the cloud it's
never date it's never date time short
it's always an explicit um value but
that explicit value varies depending on
your geo location inferred geo location
okay i didn't even realize i didn't
realize they never matched are you still
on the opposite side of the world jesse
you could demo this if you're still on
the opposite are you still on the
opposite side of the world yes i am
i'm checking
where in the world
as far as the cloud's concerned i'm in
champaign oh okay
where in the world is jesse friedman
i'm in south korea
oh cool
um
okay so the proposal is just to no
longer set it by
dollar geolocation
you mean to not have this happen yes
that's that's correct right jesse
yes that's correct that's the proposal
is to just remove this all of the
special logic that the cloud does
regarding dollar date string format
which is to set it based on
infrared geo location
right and the right so the motivation is
you know p some some class of users get
unexpected failures because they don't
know to account for this
and the other is apparently you know
jesse is more the expert here but my
understanding is if you compare with you
know java and a lot of other languages
which have built-in
date time functionality you know the
language has a default uh
so it's we're a bit odd in that our
language has this
location development but we're also a
language actually knows something about
the world which most do not so i mean i
think well
in other languages it's more that if
there is a a function that returns a
localized uh date string it's actually
called that like locale date string or
date localized or whatever rather than
having that be the the default for the
the one uh date string function and i'll
note that we actually do have a
date a name date string format there's a
whole set of name date string formats
prefixed with locale there's locale date
short locale date full
um that are based on i think the
operating system locale rather than
anything about your infer geo location
but if there were in in theory anything
to uh have be dependent on geolocation
it would be that rather than
than the like the main default those
will show up if you go to the date
stream page
see this is where i go crazy with our
documentation we shouldn't do this
this grandfathering thing where it's not
listed separately on this page we
shouldn't do it
and and i think it's on brian's cue to
figure out a way to do it where we
actually keep all the pages in sync
instead of having 17 distinct
inconsistent copies
okay
well so what you're suggesting
is we should have yet another
family called geolocation date short or
something
i'm honestly not that convinced that the
the geolo geolocation based uh date
string thing is is that useful um if if
if anything were to change i thought
about it a little bit i thought maybe
the cloud would look at um
is the accept language http header the
browser send but um
you know machines scripts generally
don't so that includes the look how the
browser thinks that uh that the user
wants that's usually used to you know
decide what language to return but it
should be possible to infer like the
standard uh
format for the user's language basically
don't think that works for that in
america does it i thought that many of
those countries have different date
formats
even though well the
locale and the locale is something like
you know en hyphen us english as used in
the united states
okay fine so you're saying that that
would be enough information
right
one would want to test to make making
sure that it works and that browsers are
really as well behaved as i seem to
think that they are but i think that's
sort of a more uh reliable thing to go
off of than geolocation which is
right where you but too many people live
on nala island the population of
null island is in the hundreds of
millions or something well it's more
about the fact that ip goip is is
inherently uh in exact science and
sometimes very very inexact no that's
what i'm saying it lands on null island
at 0-0 or something too often for
example or or alternatively right my geo
location
correctly says that i'm in the united
states but my browser is set to prefer
hebrew web pages
so in that sense it would be
appropriate to
prefer hebrew things for me
oh so you would prefer the hebrew date
format
you know that that that's a little bit
of a edge case um um
but uh yeah i certainly i certainly
wouldn't object to it i guess is my
claim
so your claim is as soon as you set
little call for your browser
to
thing x
that you'll be okay with it using at
least okay with it using that as your
date format yep
and i just should be uh uh crystal clear
about what was at least for me the big
problem with this it was not not the
fact that in a cloud notebook yeah you
get uh different results depending on
your location but it's because it's like
with cloud apis uh uh
the
runtime behavior of a cloud api can be
unexpectedly different depending on the
location of the uh the
client that's calling it
um so that's that's why i think like uh
basing it off of the accept language uh
browser header which uh non-browser
machines usually don't send that sort of
um
uh eliminates that mostly eliminates
that issue um i still don't think it
should be the default i think it should
be this look
that that behavior should only kick and
it's one of these
locale based state formats but um i
think it that helps with
that further eliminates the possibility
of of uh
code behaving
unexpectedly differently than the author
intended um because the author didn't
realize that they're getting a locale
based uh day format
jesse thank you for being up at this
ridiculous time of day
you're welcome is is that a a
a system function i don't know about
local time
yeah
okay
now you do yep now i do
i usually just call date object with you
know a time zone or a specification this
is a good way to do this
um
one command data string dollar data
string format affects date string and
date object
and in a sense date object is safer
because it inserts
the date format if it's not default
so i wonder whether there is any
consequence there wait wait a second so
let's just summarize what we think we
want to do
so jesse is making the point that for
you know generic programmatic purposes
date
time short
should be the default for dollar date
string format
there is the option by the user to make
it local date string short
in which case they're going to use a
browser local if a browser or call is
provided if no local is provided it will
fall back to being date string short
again
um
and that
this
cleverer than than
whatever
thing for the cloud will go away
and the cloud in the case of cloud
evaluate
even though it might have some guess
from goip but it probably wouldn't from
cloud evaluate but even though it might
have some guests from goip we will not
use that we will only use local
information which will only be available
for browsers
um
uh
ethan has commented on our live stream
about orphan engines running in aws
clouds and in different zones no this
will not affect that i mean the the
question of the local time zone is a
different question right how is that
being handled
that's being handled based on the system
clock isn't that correct
what does the system clock have the time
zone
i'm i'm now uh so in in
right so so the actual system clock uh
you know the hardware system clock does
not but in any reasonably modern
operating system
it knows and it translates and it
basically right basically your os
settings tell say is the hardware clock
set to utc or is it set to local time
and then the
os takes the
the care of translating everything and
if that setting is wrong then you'll
notice it because your
computer will never match what your you
know phone or watch says
record we have sorry recall that we have
dollar system timezone which is supposed
to be the computer time zone dollar time
zone is the time zone that you can set
yourself
okay and which by default
is dollar system times
okay i think that's a well i don't know
where i hit
um
right so presumably right this went to
our
to our little
local loca uh colo
and and right which is why you're
getting central time for your cloud
evaluate
right
oh it all looks correct
okay and this is what jesse got off vpn
oh okay that's totally different that is
a
but jesse the
i don't know how far your korean
language learning has gone but it is
your local setting to korean or or still
or america or
well it's u.s but that's irrelevant this
is this should be based on my ip address
only
okay okay
fine and year month day
is is
correct 12 and 24 hour form uh format
are both used here
okay okay
well so in other words all right so this
was a success but we don't think it was
the right thing to do
so i think how we how we converge on
what we think the right thing to do is
fairly straightforward
it's just we remove this cleverness here
and we support and document
properly this local
date
string format
that sounds like what we agreed to okay
anybody does anybody disagree with that
no i i don't disagree but i would like
to understand and this is probably a
separate discussion with jesse about
what is it that he that fails when using
the
the other because
all that competition
it's it's not it's not a problem with
date computation itself it's a problem
with um when people developers uh
mistakenly assume that uh or
or
don't even realize that they're
mistakenly assuming that uh date string
always returns something in a fixed
format
so it was i mean it's it's it's
fundamentally um
uh
uh
when this behavior combines with a bug
or with a
poor coding practice but it nevertheless
happened and it caused at least for me
um uh uh some pretty annoying problems
because it's very it's very difficult to
diagnose why your cloud object is
working fine for users in the us
including yourself but not for users
outside of the country
right i mean it's a slight
you know
protecting people from not having read
the documentation but it's probably a
reason well actually no it's not this
isn't documented the geolocation
changing stuff in the cloud is not
documented it is implied by the fact
that um a dollar date string format says
there's a note to the effect of
something like it is typically
date short that's all it says
how disgusting okay
is this a typo i.e lat n
[Music]
okay it's a separate yeah i don't know
looks like it
yeah
um
okay
i think we're done with this topic is
that true
i think so
okay we should let jesse go and thank
you jesse for
for
um
being here for this
no problem thank you for agreeing with
me
[Music]
thanks jesse bye
bye
uh i'm gonna drop as well so thanks okay
sounds good
okay
right so right now if you
use equal as as opposed to same q right
i mean everybody i think agrees on what
right same few things should actually be
the same
now now users sometimes use equal with
colors and if they happen to be the same
color space
then it will
you know evaluate but if
if it's not then it'll just return
unevaluated which is what i showed there
okay so is that proposal to do something
different or is are we proposing some
color equal weirdness
we're proposing no we're the color equal
is just the prototype that people are
whipped together but basically the
proposal is equal
if all the arguments to equal are in
fact color cue
then convert them to i think it's xyz
color whichever you know a universal
color space and compare them there
question
so
uh for example with unicode characters
that have we just went over this with
combiner characters and things
equal does not do something special in
that case is that a true statement
that is a true statement
do we like that
um
or should it in fact do normalization
which i don't think will be stupid at
all
um does
okay um
[Music]
yeah and i have another question here
which is that
i guess pattern matching is a same cue
story right yes
right i mean you can obviously do
something with pattern test and say is
this thing equal to something and get at
it that way but if you're doing actual
pattern matching then it's
right
well i mean i think it would be
enhancing equals
which
is a good thing i just i'm wondering
what other cases there are where we can
generalize that idea
i mean like like for example
if i have a sparse array
and i have a dense array that is the
same array
well equal already handles that
let me see that and then he and then
he's structured array as well so okay so
if i say round if i just make a random
array
okay and i say sparseray
nice right and if well then then it's
going to be easy to sell me on the color
case
i'm sure i've implicitly used that what
what that just did many times i haven't
really thought about it which is good
but again i i want to i want to raise
the question i think combiner characters
should work this way too
remember our related discussion in terms
of entities
should two entities be
equal under equal and and we rejected it
in that case because it was potentially
too too much of a slippery slope
well that one has bizarre time dependent
stuff
what was an example of that that that
was
what's an example of that
well
um
country entities and historical country
entities
oh yeah yeah right oh that is an
absolute unbelievable can of worms
um
yeah
no i i agree that that's i mean in the
hierarchical entities discussion we're
having there will be some additional
kind of things like that
but
i think it's a separate issue okay let's
talk about the color case is there
something
um
is there something controversial here or
is it fairly straightforward we promote
to a universal color space and do the
comparison
so color yeah colors i think is
relatively uncontroversial i guess i we
should give anybody who has an objection
a chance to object but i haven't heard
any objection to that
so something with an alpha channel of
one
is the same as something without an
alpha channel true statement
yes
okay
okay
what about image equality
in different colored faces so that is
that is the the next bullet point in in
the section which is
you know what do you do if if things
right so there i i chose in fact an e a
slightly
even simpler equate
problem of you know image but you change
image size is that still
the same image or not i think so
i think so
right okay so i'm to make it even more
difficult what about graphics
we don't have sophisticated equality
testing for graphics
we do not you'll see that right that
example right there
right so as far as i know we don't have
any precedent for
you know ignoring options in equal um
right so graph if the options are
different returns false graphics just
returns unevaluated
um yeah and i don't right in fact then i
don't even
i know brett can probably speak better
to this point but it's not even clear to
me what it necessarily means for two
graphics to be equal if you have
they paint ink in the same places
but they might have a rectangle or they
might have a polygon
yeah i was wondering whether we
you know have
some
hierarchy of equivalency on things
yes i mean the question is what is the
meaning of equivalence right it's it's
some
boy this relates to our observer theory
from physics project and all kinds of
crazy things
right and and and for example i mean i
think i mean i i can't claim to know
what are all the options to image off
the top of my head but i you know i i
interlight thing with how the
interlacing is done right but
on some level there's still you know
some basic raster which we're
treating as a numeric array
numerical array that we're comparing and
and that i sort of understand
but with graphics
you know axis goes to true or false is
that you know
i'm i don't know if people would agree
on whether those two graphics are the
same they certainly look different
um right well let me point out a major
precedent that we have
okay
which is
uh
okay what's that gonna do
kaboom
right but if you if you look at n of 278
you'll see that that was stripped before
it was parsed i know
in this direction there is a danger that
we might break some equations in which
users used strange objects as variables
i see so your point is
let's say there was a let's say that we
had the case of
uh
clearly
we better not think that um red and blue
are the same there
right or equal to green yeah
right i think jose was more worried
about the case where somebody had blue
circle equal to
you know 24
or green circle
yes i don't want the faults they're
amazing
perhaps those are my x and y
sorry i don't understand green watch
what if you write x equal equal y it
stays unevaluated so i could still write
blue circle equal
red circle and want it to stay
unevaluated
sure
right which right we might we would be
breaking if we started having graphics i
see i see what you're saying
so you can't do that i mean if i say
string aaa
equals equals string bb
it's false
right so in other words strings we're
treating as literals
and the question is how far do we go and
treating so right now if i have the red
color swatch
and i say red equals equals blue
i get that
so the proposal is to change that
right which i think
you know i think with red and blue it's
relatively
uncontroversial in fact in fact i'm a
bit surprised that doesn't evaluate
right because shouldn't those both
evaluate to an rgb color and we look at
full form of n of 280 it is an rgb color
it's just it doesn't it doesn't resolve
okay
well okay well i thought because of the
heads were the
same well i guess i guess it was right
if right
that's just gonna stay like that okay
right whereas f of one equals f of one
well give true
yes
right i was i was momentarily confused i
apologize um
so
yeah so i guess we are potentially
breaking that but i think
you know
i know i guess i feel like
uh
i i know i don't know is jose are you
actually objecting to colors
uh giving red equal blue giving false or
or
or is it really the graphics case that
you're
are you drawing a distinction between
them or are you including them
well the question is
good
i'm more worried about the general idea
of going of going too far with equal so
in my opinion equal has always been a
bit careful
with this type of thing it
i find it to
to stay and evaluate it
more than i was expecting it sometimes
i'm sorry so which you're saying with
colors it stays more unevaluated than
you expected or what i mean colors might
be a casing which i might be
okay
but
now that we are going into graphics
graphics is still
i mean i can see the graphics a bit too
much
right because graphics is a is sort of a
general symbolic thing
right where yeah i guess that's sort of
my feeling colors make sense to me
because they're
they're sort of
they're kind of numerical
whereas whereas graphics feel sort of
more and right graphics can be
arbitrarily nested and complicated
they're sort of luckily a symbolic thing
what you're talking about is there are
really three levels the same queue
that's equal and there's something else
there's
is it somehow equivalent
like similar q or something
equal by
i see
well that's interesting because let me
let me point out something that in our
uh grading system for the question
answering stuff
this
you know
is x plus one all squared equal to x
squared plus two x plus one
if you're doing advanced math those two
things are equal if you're trying to
learn basic algebra those things two
things are not to be considered equal
mm-hmm
right if the problem is expand x plus
one so here it does
then
so that's an important case which we are
now handling in some way for the
assessment functions
and i think maybe we should learn from
that in other words what what
yeah in fact in fact now that i think
about it that
uh
project must require
uh these kinds of equivalence testing
because they also have the issue of if
if you've got a graphic is it the same
graphic
so i mean i think what i'm coming to yes
i don't think it's quite equal by but
but it's something like that
um
maybe it is that
where it has sort of a string name for
different kinds of quality testing and
that we do not do this for graphics but
we probably do do it for colors
and we draw the line at colors
um so so
are you sorry are you suggesting that we
do do this as an equal
evaluates for colors or
something
okay i'm suggesting it evaluates for
colors does not evaluate for graphics
it does not evaluate obviously for x
plus one
squared equal equal x squared plus two x
plus one
boy that's about the limit of my by hand
algebra um
the uh
um
i i'm sure that those capabilities have
atrophied in the 40 how many years is it
now
44 years that i've been doing this by
computer anyway but never mind um
the uh
and that we consider yet a new function
that plugs into the assessment framework
and that is this equal by effectively
construct
we don't have an equal buy we have an
equal two yeah actually equal buy is an
interesting name idea now that i think
about it yes i agree
comments kind of like equivalent by
better but
equivalent maybe has other meaning in
our language already i'm not sure it
does
so
you wanted yes i i want to go back to
the image case so stephen if you type
image of red equals to image of blue
it returns false right now so this is
already inconsistent with
uh
with what we have for colors
uh and i i believe we should make this
consistent image image 3d and colors
should
behave the same with equal right and i
think and i think the argument is
my understanding of the argument is that
image and image 3d are represented you
know representations of two or three
dimensional numerical arrays
and we know how to compare numerical
arrays
so i'm sorry what what what is being
argued here you're saying
that this already works so if i say
image of
if i have two different images
do they
let's say i say random image
are you saying that two different random
images
will go false
right
oh god what a this is such a freaking
disaster area
okay so you're saying if i take random
image
and i say that random image there and
then i change its size
so i take that image
and now i literally go
like this equals equals
and then i take this and then i change
its size
like that
and i compute it
oh for god
right so that that's the thing that pjot
want to change and where i was a little
bit
uncomfortable because of you know we
don't do that for i mean you'd see the
same thing in graph
and with graphics it would just return
unevaluated and maybe the arguments is
that graph and image are atom cue things
right image is atom cue right once it
actually turns into a proper image
yes
it is
oops so right so so that's the i guess
that's a good argument why image should
be you know we should actually do
comparisons with image because it's
right it's the same reason why strings
we actually compare them and
and graph we actually compare them
because they're
um
ah
that's just wrong
that's just wrong
yeah right presumably if presumably if
you did graph isomorphic q you'd get
true at impact at least i hope you'd get
true if you did better isomorphic q on
those but
so
what if you change the aspect ratio
instead of the image size
yes sort of what is the
i think it comes
this is
identical to the issues that are coming
up in this observability stuff in the
physics project
it's
just uh
another thing yeah go ahead
there is also the the seven bits of
tolerance in equal i'm wondering whether
necessarily that's going to be the case
in all these other cases we're
considering it may be that for colors
it's very important that there is no
tolerance for example or something like
that no there isn't
we are but perceptual creatures and we
can't tell the difference between red
you know perfect red and 0.999 red right
and i i i mean can correct me if i'm
wrong but i believe when you're
comparing images the difference between
same q and equal right now is that
you know same q compares the the
numerical entries with same q tolerance
and equal compares them with equal
tolerance
yes exactly if everything else matches
because we compare all the options then
then we're looking at numeric rise that
store pixel data and we use different
tolerance for comparing numeric arrays
this is the this okay the picture we
have on the screen here of a graph in
two sizes and whether they're equal is
the nub of our problem
i bet christopher would have an opinion
about this
what would christopher say what would
his opinion be oh i think we all have
opinions about this
whether we are not necessarily not
necessarily the same opinion i know but
i i think
my initial opinion about this is
this should be true
but if you turn the graph green
should it be true
probably not
if you change the vertex sizes should it
be true
let's just say we have 10 people in the
meeting and we probably have at least 11
opinions
the more i think about this
the more i think this is an abuse of
equal and we need some new symbol in
which we can specify in the second
argument what are we looking for
and then you can what do you think this
should do do you think this should
remain unevaluated
with equal probably unevaluated
but
with that new symbol then we can specify
in the second argument whether
size matters or not yeah i know an equal
buy type thing right exactly
yes if we have that symbol a lot of
things can return unevaluated for equal
and
if you want and then
[Music]
would
yes
that we should
back out of everything
you know we shouldn't do colors with
equality we should just keep what we
have with the quality testing and not
test anymore
well i don't know raw colors i'd
probably be okay with
he says
i think i'd be okay with that one
because i think they are well okay so
changing direction for a moment and i
haven't tested this
you know what does equal do for
say two geo positions of
differing precision
does it use the seven bit thing jose or
one
well if it does automatically for
example it has been suggested several
times that
uh if you have two geopositions in which
the longitude varies by 360 degree
equal should return true and and it does
it doesn't right now but again it's one
of these cases in which i always
consider it's a slippery slope
i think i i think what look what we're
concluding is we need equivalent by
or something and we need to give it a
second argument and
uh you know the real thing to state in
the second argument is what is it
like
you know examples of second arguments so
if we imagine a um
you know equivalent by
or equal by
let's say rather equal by and then we
say something like
geo1go equal is verox isn't it
it's a good reason to call it equivalent
by
okay so let's say one geo two
ah we're going to need a varax form of
this but we can
we could presumably that fold
if you have to
i was thinking it would be a list in the
first argument actually
eric what about the following
possibility that there's a
the following works
um
criterion and then in the curried form
it can take a bearags
that would seem quite nice to me
that it's single
that that form
works like that
but then the the curried form can work
with
what about only having the curried form
and like you can do
empty brackets for some automatic
default and
[Music]
you know i'm not sure
let's write down what some of the
criteria are okay
so okay what are the categories we've
got numbers
uh
and i think that things like
you know issues are eg
complex numbers
with zero imaginary part
or maybe those are simplified
automatically i don't know
they don't necessarily simplify
automatically but i mean equal we'll
ignore
right a real and a complex that uh
you know with matching real parts and
zero imaginary parts are equal to each
other right but so what i'm saying is
that equivalent buy should allow one to
even back off from that kind of equality
for months too
so the various precision things here
numbers
eg
numbers have to have
the same precision to be equal that
could be one thing you'd want
i mean if you if it's really an
equivalent by right you might ask for
like parity when comparing
uh
what kind of parity even or odd like if
you're comparing
integers you might want the
equivalence by parity
i see
that's i consider that more obscure
okay so
we've got geo well i mean equivalent
modulo
you know some number is
you know the first you know one of the
first equivalences you you get to in
math
but i mean then then
right i mean then it is basically mod
but yeah right
i mean that's
it might be syntactically nice to be
able to say something like this
and then the alternative is
uh
well i don't know numerical value or
something i don't know what quite what
that means but but um
uh okay there's geo
there's graphs
there's images
so in graphs it would be something like
graph connectivity equivalent by graph
connectivity i.e
don't care about styling
or even
embedding
yeah
that's basically equivalence of edge
lists or adjacency graphs or whatever
uh
and then
there would be
uh somebody is typing rather loudly
um
appearance i.e
ignore size i'm not sure it's the right
name
but everything else
matters
i mean it's kind of like graph form
pretty soon we'll be going to
aristotle's theory of causes
uh
but you go you get what i'm saying here
ignore the size where everything else
matters
yep
and probably graph embedding is a
separate one that
you can have
you know whatever styling you want as
long as
i see
i see yeah that's probably another case
um
across on our bloodstream mass with
equivalent by if criterion g01go2 is
equivalent to equal of the of the crits
of the geos no it isn't
it's more complicated than that because
for example in the case of numbers with
numerical precision there's a
complicated containment
thing that has to be tested
so it really is a thing it really has
content
just in pure
uh you know it has unique content
related to the it's equivalent by
criterion
um whoever's typing loudly please
the
um
okay so so what other categories are
there other than these so geo
it's this question of longitude
modding
yeah or whether for example they have
the same data
yes yes same
you know
okay so this is
geo by geo position
which means that it doesn't matter ie
don't care about the
i mean if it was a geo grid position
being equal to a geo position
maybe that's confusing
don't care about how the point in the
earth is how
the point on the earth
is specified
just where it is
i'm not sure that's the right name for
that but that concept is there
um i was going to say we potentially
also get into cases where you know
whether a
multi-geo position is equal to a list of
equivalent geo positions
there's what if the steel position is on
an electron then 360 degrees isn't
enough to be equivalent
date will be another area
yes that's an important one
you're making me wonder about fermionic
black holes
in super symmetrical gravity that must
be a thing
is it guys
are there black holes that are
effectively feminic so that they have
spinner
um
so they don't have
360 degree
identity rotations
my physics moment question at least two
people here might have a serious opinion
about that i don't know of any off the
top of my head but i don't
see an obvious reason why it's
impossible in sugar
i've never heard of it
meaning that
black holes tend to be very large so
yes
quantum numbers
right
but
but they can still be feminic if they
happen to be a half integer
whatever except i don't think anybody
thinks about that
um okay anyway so uh and your point
would be that it also went that in super
gravity it would come
you know
if there's a bosonic black hole there
must be
its
bermionic super partners exactly
and yet this rings no belts
nor for me
okay we've got
three at least
yeah probably arguably four physicists
at least here
and
all right we'll have to i'll have to
investigate that that is a quite
separate discussion
which we didn't expect
it'll be streamed tomorrow
actually there is a i'm looking up here
um
huh
wow
there is some
literature on
oh
my gosh this one here on on fermionic
vacuum around a curved black hole
spontaneously decays to form a
co-rotating fermi c
okay there's a huge mess associated with
this probably
um
okay
onward
uh
okay
dates
yeah clearly even time zone equivalents
what do we do with that right now
two dates that are the same time in
different time zones are they the same
or not
i think so if if if they are equivalent
under
time zone convert i think they are
considered the same
and they're equal now i understand so so
you're saying if i say now
and then i say time zone convert
that to utc can i do that yes
okay now i say percent
298
oh wow
so dates are another we bet we've got to
inventory and we've got to put this on
the equal
page
which of these things has this kind of
auto auto checking because we found
colors do no colors do not
dates do
images do
yeah okay so this page is pathetically
inadequate
for example another case in which i
implemented equality is permutation
groups if you have two permutation
groups
given by different generators but
representing the same group they do
return through android one
wow
okay that's one i wouldn't have seen
coming necessarily
in in a sense i always thought of equal
as being mathematical so when it's
mathematical objects
it's kind of
better defined
in maths there's a tendency to have
uniquely defined the quality of it it's
not always the case
your point is that they're not same cube
but they're equal just like one and one
point
right well that's a bad example because
the fact that the
that on the number line one and one
point
you know it's a hack that we have this
one point concept on the number line
um
yeah sandra is asking about sound video
and audio
i have no idea yeah piotr what do
uh the own video um
well
well
video is probably impossible right
because it's just the url
well
we just merged the pr that so it's going
to be new in 13.1 unless we decide to
change it now
that we're looking at the
file location
i mean the first argument for video
object is this file or url but that
and and if
basically you know find file returns
true for for both
then
letters the same the same string for
both them and then they are equal
positive is the important one that is if
the urls are unequal
do you then assume that the videos are
not the same
um so video of url in
13.0 already if i'm not mistaken
downloads that url before it returns so
we always have a local file created and
we but the question no that's not the
question steven's asking the question is
if you get two different values for
string val for string for find file
do do you return false
i believe so
yeah but
we have few options of video object that
we also consider
for equal
like specifying the tracks video tracks
audio tracks if
you know if if they don't match that
then
we need to wrap this this discussion but
um
uh
okay what's needed here is a proper
inventory of what equal is doing right
now
and all of these various oh by the way
there's the special equality test here
okay
and um
yeah
the the the short answer is we're
deciding not to make any changes right
now until we've completed this inventory
i think we could do the color thing i'm
not worried about the color thing with
raw colors but anything to do with
images graphics etc we need the
inventory we also need to interact with
the assessment function folk to find out
what they've done
okay can you tell me who the assessment
functions folks are
or can you ever tell me who they are
because i don't know who they are well
steven schroeder is a good person to
start with
yeah i got that i can forward that along
okay
um
okay
i think that's it for
for
for now here okay
good